قبل وصولي إلى هنا خضع هذا المريض
لعملية قلب مفتوح ود.
يشرف CERN mez و John على
شفائه بعد أن كانت العواقب
مؤلمة للغاية وهم يراقبون عن كثب
علاماته الحيوية أن
هذا المريض يعاني من ارتفاع في ضغط الدم.
الألم لكن أطبائه يعرفون أن هذه
الأدوية يمكن أن تخلق التبعية وليست
دائمًا كافية لتخفيف المعاناة ، لذا
فهم يحاولون شيئًا لم أره من
قبل
[موسيقى]
العلاج بالموسيقى له جذور قديمة جدًا هنا في
تركيا
اعتقد العثمانيون القدماء أنهم يستطيعون ذلك
علاج المرض واستعادة التوازن بين
العقل والجسم باستخدام
مجموعات فريدة من النوتة الموسيقية الموجودة في
الموسيقى الصوفية ومن غير العادي أن ترى
الرجل الذي يبدو أنه مخدر
يستجيب غريزيًا هو أن الموسيقى تعطي بعض الرسائل
كل شيء في حالة جيدة أنت في
البازلاء لا تتألم
[تصفيق]